FOR THAT.
THAT IS INTERESTING AS HELL.
THANK YOU.
>> THANKS, TUCKER.
>> Tucker: SOME EXCLUSIVE
DETAILS TONIGHT RELATED TO THE
RUSSIA PROBE IN A LETTER
OBTAINED BY THE SHOW, THE
ATTORNEY ROGER STONE HAS ASKED
THE WHITE HOUSE TO DECLASSIFY
ANY MATERIALS THAT WOULD REVEAL
WHETHER STONE WAS SPIED UPON BY
THE FBI.
THERE IS SOME EVIDENCE THAT HE
WAS.
AND IF HE INDEED WAS, HE WOULD
JOIN CARTER PAGE AND PAUL
MANAFORT AS INDIVIDUALS
CONNECTED TO THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN
WHO WERE SPIED ON WITHOUT THEIR
KNOWLEDGE.
SO FAR THE WHITE HOUSE HAS NOT
COMMENTED ON THAT LETTER.
A FORMER CAMPAIGN ADVISER JOINS
US TONIGHT.
THANK YOU FOR COMING ON.
THIS IS A STRAIGHTFORWARD
REQUEST.
AN INTERESTING REQUEST.
IS THERE ANY REASON THAT THE
WHITE HOUSE WOULD NOT HELP THE
REST OF US KNOW WHETHER STONE
WAS SPIED ON.
>> FIRST I WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT IT IS UNDERSTOOD THAT I AM
NOT IN CONTACT WITH ROGER STONE
PRETTY IS MY BEST FRIEND, BUT
THE COURT WILL NOT ALLOW ME TO
SPEAK TO THEM.
I HAVE NOT SPOKEN TO HIM OR
CONTACTED HIM IN ANYWAY SINCE
THE DAY HE WAS ARRESTED.
>> Tucker: WE HAVE A
FIRST AMENDMENT STILL IN THIS
COUNTRY.
I DON'T KNOW IF THE JUDGE
ACKNOWLEDGES THAT.
WHY IN THE WORLD COULD A JUDGE
TELL YOU WHO YOU CAN TALK TO AS
AN ADULT TAXPAYER IN THIS
COUNTRY?
>> RIGHT, AND OF COURSE, THEY
DID NOT EVER SEND ME TO THE
GRAND JURY, THE MUELLER TEAM.
I'M NOT ON A WITNESS LIST, BUT
FOR SOME REASON IT IS VINDICTIVE
THAT WE ARE NOT ALLOWED TO SPEAK
TO EACH OTHER PRAYED ROGER AND I
HAVE KNOWN EACH OTHER FOR 30
PLUS YEARS, SOMETIMES WE TALK 30
PLUS TIMES A DAY.
I TALKED HIM OFF AT THE CEILING
IN STRESSFUL TIMES.
BUT I HAVE NOT SPOKEN TO HIM
SINCE HE WAS ARRESTED.
I'M STILL SHOCKED ABOUT THAT.
BUT I REALLY BELIEVE THAT WHAT
THE ATTORNEY FOR ROGER STONE
REQUESTED SHOULD BE GRANTED.
IN MY OPINION, IT IS NOT JUST
ROGER STONE, IT IS CARTER PAGE
WHO SURVEILLANCE DOCUMENTS NEED
TO BE REVEALED.
ROGER AND ME NOT TO -- BY THE
TIME THIS INVESTIGATION THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE IS OVER
WHEN WE MIGHT SEE THIS MATERIAL
AT THE EARLIEST, ROGER STONE'S
TRIAL MAY ALREADY BE OVER.
IN FACT, IT PROBABLY WILL BE.
SO ON REDACTING THEM AND
RELEASING THEM AT THAT POINT
DOES NOT HELP ROGER STONE AT
ALL.
IT DOES NOT REVEAL ALL OF THE
CHICANERY AND PROBABLY
LAWBREAKING THAT WENT INTO
SURVEILLING ROGER STONE.
BUT IT IS THE SAME WITH CARTER
PAGE.
AND BY THE WAY, GENERAL FLYNN IN
SOME WAY, SHAPE, OR FORM AS
WELL.
THERE WAS A LOT OF SURVEILLANCE
GOING ON AND WE NEED TO KNOW
WHAT IT IS.
AND WE NEED TO KNOW NOW.
>> Tucker: WHY WHEN IT'S THE
WHITE HOUSE HELP US KNOW?
THAT'S WHAT I DO NOT UNDERSTAND.
AND YOU ARE CORRECT.
AT THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN WAS SPIED
UPON BY THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION
PAID WE KNOW THIS, SO WHY DON'T
WE HAVE THE RIGHT TO KNOW THE
DETAILS OF IT?
>> A LOT OF THIS I DO NOT
UNDERSTAND.
ABOUT THREE OR FOUR MONTHS AGO
THE PRESIDENT SAID HE WAS ALL
SET TO DECLASSIFY FISA DOCUMENTS
AND DEMAND EMAIL OR TEXT
MESSAGES BETWEEN ALL OF THE
DIFFERENT FBI AGENTS WHO WERE
PLOTTING THIS WHOLE HOAX.
AND WE NEVER SAW THAT STUFF.
AND A LOT OF THE STUFF I DO NOT
UNDERSTAND.
BUT I'M SURE THAT THE PRESIDENT
HAS A PLAN.
I JUST VISITED THE PRESIDENT IN
THE OVAL OFFICE RECENTLY.
WITHOUT -- WE DID NOT TALK ABOUT
ROGER STONE.
WE WERE CAREFUL NOT TO PRAY TO
THE PRESIDENT KNOWS THAT HE IS
MY BEST FRIEND.
AND I MET THE PRESIDENT THROUGH
ROGER STONE IN 1988.
WE WERE CAREFUL NOT TO EVEN
MENTION HIS NAME, BUT HE IS
PAYING VERY CLOSE ATTENTION TO
THIS IN THE LETTER FROM THE
LAWYER, I THINK THAT HE MIGHT
HEED IT.
LET ME TELL YOU SOMETHING, HE
AND THE FIRST LADY NEW CHAPTER
AND FIRST OF WHAT MY FAMILY WENT
THROUGH, AND I KNOW THAT THE
PRESIDENT IS PAYING ATTENTION TO
FAR MORE PEOPLE THAN JUST US.
>> Tucker: WILL BE NICE TO SEE
SOME PARDONS, A PARTNER AND OF
ROGER STONE PRAYED >> I AM
REALLY WORRIED ABOUT DON JR.
WITH THE SENATE COMMITTEE.
>> Tucker: THE WHOLE THING IS